well here in las vegas we are all
feeling the effects of inflation and
some much more than others jeremy j ford
spoke with working families who now need
to utilize community resources for
additional help just to get by
with inflation currently on the rise
more and more people are showing up to
places like this catholic charities to
seek help i just think it's affecting
everybody right now obviously
everything's super expensive giancarlo
tells me he comes from a single income
household and right now times are hard
it could get difficult so
yeah i mean it just everything is very
very high right now forcing him to seek
local resources for help with essential
needs i've never
had to get any type of assistance i
never thought i would but i mean you
just got to do what you got to do right
like getting help from food pantries
like catholic charities the food pantry
is probably where we see the highest
impact because that's the first that's
really the first line that people hit
particularly with inflation that's
hitting their pocketbooks with gas and
food making getting assistance something
steve schmidt says you shouldn't be
embarrassed about we're all in this
community together you will probably
come down and see families from your
neighborhood
in that line so there's no shame in it
because sometimes we all need just a
little bit of help it's not just
affecting one individual is affecting
everybody maybe pushing the ego to the
side for a bit just think of the big
picture jeremy j ford live local now
jeremy thank you for that well if you
need assistance catholic charities
encourages that you stop by their
facility no questions asked now there
are several other organizations that
offer services and food as well three
square has daily distribution locations
if you're interested we have a link on
our website eight newsnow dot com